I was born in Russia and came over when
I was very little.
I was six and a,
I grew up outside of Boston.
My parents,
first they lived in Brighton,
which is where the Russians start out.
And then they gradually moved west.
They moved to Brookline and then they
moved to Newton and that's where they
stopped.
And now some people,
they move out to Lincoln and conquered,
um,
where they're not very many Russians at
all.
But in,
uh,
in Newton,
there are a few Russians.
So I'm partly from Moscow and I'm partly
from Newton.
Um,
and those,
those things have shaped me and complex
and confusing ways.
If my parents were from a particular
millia in,
in Russia,
a particular intellectual,
social millia,
my mom was a literary critic and,
um,
then they came to Newton,
where they sort of managed to
reconstruct that,
uh,
with the other Russians that were there.
Um,
but it was cut off.
It was a world that they were cut off
from the American world that surrounded
them.
So it was sort of island of a Russian,
a computer programmers and
intellectuals,
um,
in a prosperous American suburb.
Um,
and for me that was,
um,
it was confusing because I very much
wanted to be an American.
I wanted to,
uh,
fit in with the rest of the kids.
And,
um,
I wanted to engage with American life.
I wasn't,
I didn't want to sit at home with my
parents and the Russian books and
drinking tea all the time.
Um,
but at the same time,
I,
I knew I could,
I sensed,
even though I didn't acknowledge until a
bit later,
that,
uh,
my parents were,
it was a very rich world.
Um,
and I didn't really understand it very
well until I started going back to
Russia when I was in my early twenties,
and,
and seeing the world that they'd come
from and,
and understanding what their place in
that world had been.
Um,
and that's been
something that I have been sort of
working and thinking about,
uh,
for a while.
And,
and,
and this book is really the first time
that I've actually,
uh,
really started getting added.
Uh,
the book is,
it's not about,
it's not about Russian immigrants by any
means.
Uh,
but that's kind of in the background.
Um,
the problem of,
of being a person who,
who has a lot of ideas,
um,
uh,
comes a culture that's filled with
ideas,
um,
and is confronted with an American
reality that is not particularly
interested in ideas at all.
So my parents growing up,
there was just no context for them.
Um,
they were these strange people,
uh,
living on woodcliff road,
um,
in,
in our little house.
Um,
and then when I was going to Moscow in
the 90s,
I found a whole world of people just
like my parents.
Um,
and so,
uh,
it just put them into a context that I
could understand
for me with regard to this stuff,
a very important experience was toward
my,
uh,
toward the end of my senior year when I
was working on my thesis.
I was,
um,
I was a major,
my major was Russia and America,
but I ended up writing on a ts Elliot,
who is neither really even,
not even very American.
Uh,
he had spent a lot of time in England,
um,
but one of the,
uh,
one of the groups of people that,
that Elliot meant the most to in the
states where these people are on the
partisan review.
And,
um,
I didn't,
I hadn't really known about these people
at all.
Um,
they're not,
uh,
they weren't really part of the college
curriculum.
Um,
and they were,
uh,
and I discovered these people who
basically were first generation
immigrants from Russia.
Um,
so a Philip Rov,
the editor of the partisan review was
actually Ivan Greenberg.
Um,
he,
he was born in Russia,
came over when he was little,
um,
saul bellow as born in Petersburg.
Um,
and,
and his parents left when he was still a
baby.
Um,
and so these people who are all been
born around 1920,
um,
so they were the age of my grandparents
had actually had very similar
experiences to me,
um,
in a way where they had,
uh,
their parents were,
were,
were foreigners.
They didn't speak English very well.
Um,
and yet they very much wanted to be part
of a American intellectual life.
So discovering those people and feeling
like I,
in fact,
I had a very similar experience to those
people and that they were,
um,
a much more experience that was much
more like mine than,
than that of my contemporaries that of
my American Jewish contemporaries.
Uh,
that was a very,
uh,
important experience for me.
And that has allowed me to,
um,
I think develop a way of,
of writing about Russia and thinking
about Russia,
thinking about this place that I had
come from.
And that had been very important to me
and certainly to my reading development,
um,
or writing about it in America because
that's what these people had done.
And they were all still very interested
in Russia and the Soviet Union.
Um,
and they were,
they were using these things to
understand American life.
So,
you know,
so irving Howe and,
and,
uh,
Saul bellow or people who,
who have helped me a great deal.